Politicians blame video games for some of the violence in the world,
Since the top five games currently deployed are sniper and shooting games,
Will the game become reality and aggression on the ground?
Do video games make you aggressive?
One of the most critical criticisms against video games is that it motivates the child to be aggressive,
In this type of unconscious stimulation, the stimulus affects the reaction of another stimulus,
For example, when I say "yellow", the words that remember the fruit name,
It is likely to say "bananas."
This led scientists to conduct a study,
Where participants chose a game from one of two games,
The first game is driving and avoiding collision,
While the second game is a mouse escaping from a cat,
After the end of the game, based on the concept of stimulation,
Scientists assumed that players would be able to classify game-related forms
And quickly on the ground.
So the players looked at different images such as: bus image and dog image,
They were asked to classify them as "vehicles" or "animals"
Those who played the "car" game were slower in choosing the "vehicle" category,
Those who played the game "cat" were slower in choosing the "animal" category,
In fact, those who played both games had a slower reaction,
This explains the occurrence of negative stimulation,
It is science and its strange interpretations,
Unlike the old (8-bit) games,
The designers of the games are now able to produce wonderful designs,
So another criticism,
That the more realistic the game, the more the concept of aggressive behavior
To study this concept,
Players have chosen one game of combat (Kombat),
The characters are simulated in the first game through procedural stirring (Rachdol Fezix)
The movements of the skeleton of man,
This means a realistic simulation of death.
In the other game, the scenes were not real to die,
This was followed by the measurement of aggressive behavior by testing the "word-linking"
In the real game of death, there is no rise in aggressive behavior.
Often in current research, there is no connection between video games and aggression
One of the broad analytical studies has shown the positive side between games and aggression,
Criticizing the ineffective laboratory aggressive tests,
Tests such as: measuring brain waves or heart beat,
Which do not necessarily prove a real aggressive behavior.
In the past, where there is a relationship, it is negligible
Criminals who study mass murder claim that the relationship between games and violence is a myth
In fact, in 2011, the Supreme Court ruled America
That there is no evidence of a relationship between violent games and aggressive behavior
Unfortunately, we all know what happens after a crime,
Violent video games are charged and criticized,
In fact, this distracts attention from the main causes of violence.
Translation: team translate @autrjim